Jotaro Kujo is not impressed you know
why he's not impressed because according
to my metrics of whopping seventy five
point five percent viewers have not
pushed that subscribe button for the new
order view thus granting you regular
dirtier content uploaded straight until
YouTube feed although actually you know
to be fair even if you did press that
subscribe button
well then Joe Toro is still completely
unimpressed it takes something really
special to grab this man's attention
like say a schoolboy or rat hello and
welcome to the new order video source
for everything anime and manga and today
I'm going to dive as deeply as I can
into the existence and evolution of a
certain Jotaro Kujo and I'm delving into
this because it can be a very popular
idea to call mr. Cujo a fairly flat
protagonist especially in his own part
three and I will admit I myself am
incredibly guilty of having done just
that although for the most part I do
still kind of stand by it despite the
fact that this video will attempt to
completely dispel that because it really
is not a fair blanket statement to make
at all as within the context of the
entirety of JoJo's Bizarre Adventure
Jorah undergoes some pretty incredible
growth and changes as the most recurring
Jojo in the series with his involvement
spanning 23 years of his life from his
formative teams all the way into true
adulthood and as such the developments
he makes are not to be underestimated
and when going through the series I
always found myself most excited to see
how Jethro had changed between parts
actually we do have quite a full picture
of him much more so than most
protagonists actually with the possible
exception of his grandfather Joseph but
when I think about characters like say
josuke or Jonah I always find it a bit
of a shame that they didn't carry over
we really didn't get to see another
phase of their lives like we do with
Jorah all we really had was that
condensed experience of their own series
and I mean just think about it quite
frankly being able to see Jorah a decade
on in his life would be pretty damn
phenomenal however coming back to Jotaro
we can of course start with the brief
little bits we know about his childhood
which actually paints a fairly generic
picture he was very joyous young lad who
lived on a fairly decent-sized property
and it doesn't appear that he
experienced a whole lot of hardship in
his early years there was lots of time
for him to play and he engaged in
various co-curricular activities like
track and field and like any good child
his favorite food was his mother's home
cooking the one detracting feature we
can really identify though is his father
Saddam who was a fairly successful jazz
musician but as a result of that he was
placed in the artists dilemma where to
pursue his craft professionally he
needed to be away from his
for extended periods and as such in this
case Sadao is almost always on tour
playing his music which is why we don't
even have so much as a single image of
him in the series so this did leave
Joshua to be raised by his mother Holly
and that went quite well for a while but
you know how teenagers can be and
puberty hit Jotaro pretty damn hard
just as with most members of the Joestar
family under such Joshua turned into a
delinquent and in fact his very first
line in the series consists of telling
his mother to shut up while Giroux
himself was in prison for beating up the
cohort of gang members so already Jojo
is undergone quite an evolution from his
childhood to the beginning of Stardust
Crusaders where we find him at the age
of 17 and what we as an audience are
faced with initially is a radically
different protagonist in many ways Jorah
begins as an anti jonathan style
presence whereas jonathan was a
gentleman at all times Jorah has very
little regard for the intricacies of
polite society or even those are basic
manners however I will say that this
characterization did shift pretty
radically as soon as he was let's say
released from prison and informed with
the situation regarding do as well as
having his mother's life thrown into
peril Jorah became our significantly
more familiar part3 figure a very stoic
serious and no-nonsense existence
generally highly focused and extremely
unelectable for a seventeen-year-old
unless of course a particular stand plot
calls for him not to be that way in
which case he becomes unfathomably
negligible in addition to this he also
came to terms with his own stand star
platinum very quickly and just seemed to
instinctively have a mastery over it
which is fine given the nature of what
stands up although one of my personal
criticisms would be that with jota
restarting the series effectively
already in god mode it left very little
opportunity to develop him in this
regard until of course we reach the
finale of part 3 but something we should
also notice that despite everything
we've seen thus far Jorah was by nature
a very caring and considerate young man
very aware and even protective of those
around him and one of the greater
examples of this was when the crusaders
encountered Steely Dan who held the
lovers stand and for the sake of his
grandfather's life Jorah repeatedly
humiliated himself at Dan's mercy but
crazily enough Totoro also developed
quite a bit of respect for his enemies
or at least some of them and he even
went so far as to provide and duel with
a burial following his defeat and
subsequent suicide but the thing about
part 3 Jorah that often leaves people
including me wanting just that little
bit more is almost certainly Joe Torre's
complete
Liyana motive nature his character arc
is very very subtle and arguably
completely overshadowed by every other
member of the Crusaders including Iggy
actually but if I had to sum up Joe
Torre's journey in a simple sentence
then it would be something on the lines
of developing an understanding of the
bonds of humanity Jotaro is introduced
as a very lonely existence as I
mentioned before his father is always
gone and territorial II have any friends
and the people who are most attracted to
him are fawning fangirls who remind him
far too much of his doting mother
so what Joe wrote is presented within
Stardust Crusaders is the opportunity to
develop male bonds for the first time
both familial and friendly but the
former Giroux was able to develop a
strong relationship with his grandfather
Joseph to the point where Joseph's
quote-unquote death elicits the greatest
emotional response I think we've ever
seen from Jarrah and while I wouldn't go
so far as to call Joseph a role model in
the traditional sense he does guide Joe
to her through this adventure even if
Jojo is morphed in the notes the one who
ends up saving him and in regards to the
rest of the group Jotaro has to very
much find his place with each respected
member you can very much look at it from
the perspective of a boy learning how to
make friends for the first time so the
evolution is incredibly clear in part 3
in the beginning dirt row is a lonely
self-sufficient existence however by the
end he has learned to open himself up to
others and value human relationships I
mean just look at this
he even has this group hug thing going
on with Joseph upon aarif really I just
could never imagine this gyro ever
engaging in something like that
so look yes it is a slow burn a very
slow subtle and sometimes frustrating
burn but Joe Torre's character arc is
definitely present and that is something
that I am very much going to consider
from now on with my own criticisms of
part 3 but moving on to some even
greater leaps and bounds for Jorah we
move into pot flawed diamond is
unbreakable and by this stage about
eleven years have passed since the end
of status Crusaders and you can
immediately tell the gyro is almost an
entirely new person just judging by
aesthetics alone while he is still in
keeping with his general style gyro is
now much more schmick as opposed to his
sloppy delinquent look everything about
this Joe Torre looks organized to
perfection you know there's no more belt
straps hanging loose or tangible cues of
strength like a giant gold chain this
guy is a fully formed adult who exudes
confidence and maturity on a level that
never would have been possible for his
teenage incarnation well they're quite
notably in the manga Jotaro initially
Keynes's absurdly bulky Joestar build as
does Josie actually but our key pretty
quickly goes on to evolve his art style
into more slim builds but by this point
Jorah is also an established
oceanographer which is pretty well and
not sure what kind of career path I
would have expected him to go down but
he wholeheartedly stepped into the world
of academia which is simply fascinating
given that we originally knew him as a
school delinquent quite a shift there
but while carries over very strongly
from the end of part three his Joris
sense of familial bonds which is very
evident when he meets Tomoko for the
first time and vows to protect her from
the dangers that were about to hit Mario
as well is very willingly taking josuke
under his wing in both cases acting like
the figure that Joseph should have been
accepted by this point he's just a
little bit too old
but what really strikes me about part 4
Jojo is that he has evolved into a
leader part three Jorah may have been
confident intelligent and supremely
powerful but I would certainly never
characterize him as a leader however
upon arriving in Moria Joshua provides a
natural rallying figure capable of
concocting and implementing brand
courses of action as well as giving very
valuable advice his share maturity is
off the charts although he hasn't
changed entirely he is still a very
blunt and often curt individual who
prefers to remain silent
although he is now much more willing to
express his own opinion on various
matters and I guess he also doesn't
sweat quite as much so there is that and
with that we can briefly move into
golden wind which goes roughly two years
after Diamond is unbreakable
in the year 2001 and there isn't too
much that you can gauge from his very
short tenure in part 5 but his aesthetic
sense of certainly evolved somewhat
although he still maintains his
predominant scheme from part 4 I would
say that he appears slightly more ornate
though although the difference is far
more pronounced in the anime than it is
in manga what is most evident in part 5
territory though and this is not to be
understated is that his trust has once
again evolved this time to the point
where he entrust Koichi with an
incredibly important mission of finding
and attaining a DNA sample of her know a
cure Jono and Jorah does this because he
believes that Koichi and his stand a
better suited for the task than he would
be and not only that but he legitimately
trusts Koichi to get the job done and
then of course does he have a brilliant
moment of Jorah reminiscing of his
former comrades because by now he is
effectively the last one left
Iggy after all and kakyoin have passed
away Joseph is assumedly still alive but
in a real condition to do anything by
this
polnareff had disappeared so I think
it's just a really nice touch to see the
drawer are still treasures these
relationships that he formed in his late
teens but with that let's take a big
leap into the future once again to
examine pot six stone ocean and if you
haven't read stone ocean and you don't
want spoilers then please do feel free
to skip to this time in the video but
honestly no examination of Jotaro would
be complete without delving into this
part so here we go immediately you will
of course notice that his style has
radically shifted again and to be clear
Jotaro is 40 years old by this point and
in many ways you can argue that he has
stylistically regressed into a more
refined version of his part three look
obviously it still retains a sense of
his evolution with elements of white but
all in all
George who now chooses to dress far
Moyne formally with a fairly basic shirt
letting his belt hang out again and even
reintroducing his trademark change so
what has happened to cause the shift I
mean in his personal life dirt or
remains an accomplished adult and in
fact I believe he has even become a
professor by this point signifying his
great progress in the realm of academia
however we have a brand new stage of his
life to examine because now Jorah has a
daughter Jolene
as well as an ex-wife and his
relationship with Jolene is I guess it's
strained to say the least with George
for being a very absentee father which I
find absolutely fascinating given the
judge for his own father was always away
from home so George who is very much
followed his own father's parental style
there and has come full circle which may
be very good cause to call back a more
part 3 style look Jotaro is no longer
presented as the mature leader that
epitomized his presence in part 4 and 5
here he does a vocal or neglectful
delinquent look once again and that is a
great lens to seek him through because
it helps his characterize joram from
Jolene's point of view rather than what
we as an audience know of him from
previous parts and so I don't think it
should be a huge surprise that Jolin has
become just as much if not more of a
delinquent
then George her was himself around her
age and so George whereas our can part
six is more about Jolin discovering why
he was constantly absent and coming to
the conclusion that it was because he
was protecting her and that he always
treasured his daughter which is very
much the climax of Joshua's overlock in
George's bizarre adventure in part 3 he
learns to form bonds in parts 4 and 5 he
learns to cultivate them then in part 6
we tackle Jorah attempting to protect
those bonds especially the profound love
he has for his daughter which is
arguably the strongest bond that he
in the entire series it's a very
intriguing journey going from learning
to trust adults all the way to the other
end of the spectrum by attempting to
learn how to foster that trust with his
own child and unfortunately his grand
finale in this world would be caused by
George were prioritizing the safety of
Jolin rather than dealing with Enrico
Pucci
it's an incredibly tragic but
appropriate end for this slope on
character and of course he is assumedly
reincarnated into the universe because
Irene mentions her father and who knows
what became of this new Joe Toro and how
he differs from his previous self that
is an evolution that we will sadly
probably never get to explore but it's
also not one that we really need to see
and so over the course of four of these
eight parts
Jotaro has displayed immense growth and
it has been pretty incredible to watch
his life cycle play out with the only
other comparable character being Joseph
who is another fascinating examination
but not one for today but in conclusion
I just want to say that I do somewhat
regret any time that I have described
Rotorua's flat when in fact he does very
much present one of the most enduring
and radically shifting characters in the
series although let's be real most of
that does take place after his tenure as
main character so it doesn't necessarily
fix any issues I have with status
Crusaders but what do you guys think
please do let me know down in the
comments below or even join my discord
server and if you're keen for some more
jo-jo content then please go and check
out some of my other videos we'll even
subscribe to the channel regular Joe Joe
wander to live it straight until YouTube
feed but for now this has been the new
world review and I'll see you next time